[Music]
[Music]
okay
you know what it wasn't my fault all
right i i i had the money
like you said in a trash bag in the back
of my car and i was gonna go
straight to the drop spot
all right
no no oh okay okay okay okay no hey hey
hey hey man
ain't no need for you to get comfortable
okay because because i'm telling you man
what happened wasn't my fault all right
i i i i i i i i i drove to the agreed
upon location man
oh come in come on
okay okay okay okay
okay because there's no need to have
anything crazy
in a paper bag i'm telling you there's
an explanation for what went down
whoa whoa whoa whoa okay let's calm down
now
let's calm down man there ain't no need
oh not a juice box there ain't no need
to eat a meal
and then do some crazy with a sandwich
container
and a juice box oh man come on
come on man just chill out a little bit
just do you need to relax man you need
to take it easy and relax oh
oh god damn now come on man don't do it
don't do it
don't don't man come on man oh eating a
sandwich you eat the sandwich
oh man how you gonna sandwich me dog how
are you gonna sandwich me
oh okay look it's getting crazy now
it's gonna stop it's gotta stop right
now okay you cleaning yourself up before
you do some ill
come on man what you doing what you want
to know what i'll tell you whatever you
want to know man just please stop this
cold ass
man i'm thanking you dawg please oh
no no okay let's go again maybe it was
my fault a little bit maybe it's my
fault a little bit but don't just
what you want to do with that juice box
man we're going to do a dutch we're
going to do a straw
what are you doing with this job come on
man dude listen listen no no no i did it
i did i did it okay i did it i did i
left the car
i left for three minutes so please don't
do anything with the straw
why aren't you stuck to fire fine
okay man ha ha i beat you to it
okay i got your point all right man
huh oh man that's a [ __ ]
will we be having any more problems out
of him sir
no yeah
that's what i'm talking about
you